you don't want to lift you but a Saints
game it just it Yvette part of me just
evaporated when they lost I mean it was
like someone I mean it was like someone
you know just emancipated part of my
soul it was like they you know it was
like it was like you know like that song
like take add take another little piece
of my heart now baby man it was like
somebody just plucked the dammit a Horta
right out of my chest and just made a
damn may order gravy right in front of
me and drank it it was like somebody
just drank a-- one of my favorite pieces
of my heart it was a tough one man that
was a tough loss and and you know they
had to call i'm talking about the Saints
in Rams game and kudos to the Rams you
know but not really but also you'd I
knew it was a tough one when afterwards
nah none of my friends even wanted to
say anything on the phone we couldn't
even talk I mean you know the Saints
lost last year on that miracle play on
that million-dollar miracle and and that
was man that won that was heavy but that
happened you know and that was the day
bad defense poor tackling and then this
one though they were supposed to be
there and some things in happen I think
in life are supposed to happen they're
just supposed to it is destiny and it
was supposed to be Brees versus Brady in
the Super Bowl this going to be the
Wolves most watched Super Bowl ever even
babe even babies that were supposed to
you know be born a month from now
they're we're gonna come out early you'd
see an early you you'd see an early baby
like damn that baby
yep that thing's [ __ ] premature but
it uh it loves football you know babies
were gonna come out of the womb early to
see these two bad boys go at it
Brees and Brady Brady and Brees and and
that's what that's what the the that's
what the universe wanted that's what the
universe said here you go Saints here
you here some opportunities here's some
opportunities and and look a lot of
people want to talk about that call the
pass interference unbelievable even more
though the helmet to helmet was the
thing that got me really just felt like
somebody just hit a bunch of just damn
pop rocks
you know just deep inside of my ass and
uh man it just it was just insane how do
you mean you could hear the helmet you
could hear it at home but that but but
also the Saints had a part in it and
I've said this for years
Sean Payton too much ego man
all those men work that hard to get into
that opportunity and it's the Saints
have the balls with two minutes left and
they're in the Rams territory you run it
you just keep running it man the Rams
have to use their timeouts and you give
them the ball back with maybe 20 seconds
left or whatever or a minute left and
they have to go the whole field it just
and you're stiff and you're gonna get
your field goal it just seemed like he
you know he tried to run to many things
but Taysom Hill what do you I like I
love Taysom Hill but you have Drew Brees
brother Drew Brees is the you know if
Jesus Christ ever had an appendix and
they took the appendix out of his body
and it just showed up here on earth and
just started just dropping dimes to
people in the distance that's drew Brees
Drew Brees is the 11th
finger of Christ brother and then not
have him out there and you trying these
cutesy [ __ ] just I mean in some painter
sitting over there he got that booty his
mouth if you look at Sean Payton's his
mouth like a damn booty hole like a bee
hole sorry and I didn't mean to say that
but like a bee oh and God why in that if
he doesn't have to be cute there if he
didn't have to be fancy even if he
doesn't do all that the Saints win they
rot but but when you too much ego and I
don't make destiny it'll make destiny
say wow this guy don't want to be a part
of everything he wants to do he wants to
be cutesy he wants to be faint t he
wants to be faint too boy fancy boy and
that's the thing and it hurts and people
say well you're not a Saints fan if you
say that kind of stuff man don't say
that [ __ ] to me
I am a fan brother I mean I it's just
it's hard it's hard you know now
immediately I think of the you know a
lot of senior citizens and they're gonna
die in the next year they don't even
gonna get to see the opportunity for the
next season and this was something they
you know just a lot of full hearts
ah you know he's gonna give them that
opportunity to roll up into heaven with
a little bit a little extra [ __ ] you
know chowder and they're in their bowl a
little extra spirit chowder in their
soul Bowl and manages oh it's just
heartbreaking and I couldn't
I could not even bear to talk to some of
my friends man one buddy I called him we
sat down the phone and we couldn't even
talk and you know it just uh it just
goes like that sometimes but but being a
fan is hard isn't it
I was thinking about that being a fan
because you want something so bad but
you have no control over it
you know you but you put a lot into it
you put time in you show up and watch
the games you get you a little you know
a flag or maybe some you know a little
uh maybe shoes for the baby that have
you know little um Tennessee Titans on
them or whatever you want whatever your
team is you know Brooklyn ah I don't
know what that team is up there [ __ ]
I think this is a bunch of rappers and
people with guns really about Brooklyn
Nets you know you gay you spin you
invest you care you read the articles
you know you stay up late and you go to
your favorite reporter you go to his
Twitter timeline and see what he dropped
after the game you know you mourn the
loss when you know your mom Bushrod lost
his child you think about that during
the day you know you think about that
and you you pray for him or you think
about him and you hope that he finds
strength to continue his season and to
keep his you know just find strength for
his family and you know you just think
about a lot of these different things
and it and you care and you're there and
you want them and you see their joy and
you see and then it just I just felt
like Sean Payton a coach that way seems
selfish because you got a lot of people
whose lives are can be affected by this
moment of joy and I love my saints I'm a
Saints fan but I think that they were
supposed to win that game
and even with the call like that that's
destiny again saying look here's the
passenger and the refs [ __ ] that up
they missed that so Deadeye you know I
put it half on the referees and I but I
put half of it on on on Coach Payton I
really do man you know and well onward
bro
onward but man I was trying to go to
this dude I was driving dude driving an
Irvine man I was almost in tears in my
car man it just made me mad that Saints
the loss it just you know when I driven
back to LA the night before could my
friend had a going-away party they was
eating breakfast and then going away and
damn and I just man I was I was in the
car man I was just so just I was just
disheartened I thought the whole world
was gonna fall apart I've started
feeling just down about myself man I was
just it was just kind of a lot of
emotions I mean it'd have been an
emotional week because I get into these
shows man when I do my shows you know I
get into it I want to you know I you
know I want us to have an experience and
then and then that said this that
letdown man it felt like there was a
like there was destiny in the world and
then destiny got shook out of place and
that can happen man I just you know I
was I was so angry before the pass
interference because of the some of the
coaching I mean just play calling crazy
just pointless I don't see how Brees
doesn't say hey this isn't a good play
to call right now
but you know what I'm not a coach hell
I'm not even a player dude I'm not even
I mean my lip my legs and my butt got
tight like yesterday for no reason so
I'm not even I'm not even a waterboy but
but I'm a fan you know and being a fan
you put so much out
what do you think about being a fan I'd
love to know some of you guys as
thoughts and just on what it is to be a
fan and what goes into it and what
because here's one thing I thought I
thought this at the end of the game I
said when I was driving down to Irvine I
thought to myself I said well man if
this is the type of refereeing they're
gonna have in the games and if this is
the type of you know coaches can just
call horrible [ __ ] and and it can break
your damn heart like I don't know if I
want to watch as much or get as deep it
as I do anymore because as a fan because
the other side of the equation they're
not you know I feel like the coach
didn't do his part in the refs didn't do
their part to make it a fair fair enough
field for me to put my emotions into it
that's what I felt like so but if you
guys have thoughts on what it is to be a
fan and and what that means to you or if
you had a family member that you know
what gave it there you know just I mean
some people because I'll never play you
know I'll never there was a point in my
life when I be like oh I might get out
there and play you know I'd be sitting
on the couch at 27 you know you know
getting a couple of grams of freaking uh
that that dusty dusty that dusty Dusty
dusty and then uh next thing you know
I'm thinking in my head oh I might get
out there and play next year I might try
to audition for the New Orleans Saints
that was the kind of show the LSU you
know I'm saying things would be in my
head I'm all first of all my buddy's
like dude you're gonna audition for the
team it's called trying out you're an
idiot
do you go out there and audition you're
gonna get sent to all heaven bruh
somebody is gonna break your spine open
with a straight spine buster dude so
yeah it is but if you have thoughts on
what it means to be a fan and what it
just mean it was just so painful it felt
like part of me just was so alive and
then it was gone
like it was oh it was just gone but
thank you guys for being here with me
today man I am dude I couldn't even do
the podcast yesterday I was so upset but
I'm just so grateful to cuz I got on
stage and you know I was about to go on
stage and I was just not in a good mood
and then I did a meditation backstage
for 10 minutes you know I just sat there
and just shut it all down and put the
timer on my phone just crossed my legs
and just closed my eyes in the greenroom
and asked everybody else to leave out of
there for a few minutes and yet for 10
minutes out of sat there and just let
all the things pass that were making me
upset or whatever and they disappeared
kind of and then I got on stage man and
you know it's really a nice gift from
the powers that be in the world because
I needed to have something fun to lift
me up and 500 people lost Sunday night
at Irvine did exactly that and man that
was fun I had so much fun so thank you
guys for coming out and thank you Martin
Luther King because jr. because you knew
that I would need the day off after that
[ __ ] referee call [ __ ] and that is
[ __ ] so and that is straight B hole and
I will say that now behold